this is what extreme pressure on the NHS
looks like more than 20 ambulances
queuing outside a e here in
Stoke-on-Trent each one with a patient
inside but there's no space in the
hospital Dennis Hodgkins is among the
paramedics stuck waiting I'd say it's
the worst we've seen ever it's
heartbreaking really because you're
thinking of your the patients on the
vehicle you're trying to do your best
for and hopefully what we should be
doing is offload in 15 minutes when we
pull up we see what you can see behind
us here and we know that patient could
be waiting for for hours literally I was
only on a job a couple of weeks ago we
turned up to take a patient and they'd
been here 15 hours on the back of an
ambulance waiting
the pressure is Relentless at one point
today the number of ambulances queuing
at this one Hospital reached 32. that's
more than half the ambulances covering
the entire County of Staffordshire that
were unable to respond to 999 calls
because they were stuck here and it's
happening right across the country this
is one of several NHS Hospital trusts to
have declared a critical incident in the
last few days as hospitals struggle to
cope with the numbers of patients
needing help
a spike and flew and strep a cases
combined with a lack of social care
places to discharge patients too has led
to warnings the NHS is under pressure
like never before and there's concern
about planned further strike action by
staff
what winter is has reminded us is that
our health system is fragile and it will
continue to be fragile until we address
those big issues of Workforce the fact
that we don't have as much capital
investment the fact that we have never
really made up the ground that we lost
during the decade of austerity that was
a decade that meant we went into covert
with a hundred thousand vacancies
so things are going to be tough this
winter there'll be more trusts that will
be declared in critical incidents
Michelle Kerr say they recognize the
pressure the NHS is facing and say this
winter they've provided an extra 500
million pounds to speed up Hospital
discharge and free up beds but staff and
patients waiting here question if this
is sustainable Becky Johnson Sky News
Stoke-on-Trent